bereitet auch wegen der nostalgie und
das schafft verdruss enttäuschte
verbündete deutschland in ukraine
konflikt jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns alle gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist elende mia
hatte lacroix sie sind historikerin und
sie lehren an der universität sorbonne
in paris oder beziehungsweise haben den
lehrstuhl für
deutschland studien ihnen martin henke
ist ebenfalls professorin an der zwar
zuständig für internationale beziehungen
an der hertie school of governance hier
in berlin zugeschaltet sind wenn die
linie von riedo sie sind deutschland
korrespondentin des londoner economist
und karl heinz brunner ist bei uns bis
zur bundestagswahl
verteidigungsexperte der
spd-bundestagsfraktion es war der
bundestagswahl sind sie das nicht mehr
sie sind aber nur noch wenige tage
immerhin in ihrer funktion als
ehemaliger bundestagsabgeordneter
mitglied der parlamentarischen
versammlung der nato romy hatte lacroix
wenn man sich mal die die französische
sicht zu eigen macht aus sicht der
franzosen machen sich da die deutschen
mal wieder aus dem staub wo sie doch
eigentlich klare haltung und solidarität
zeigen sollen gemeinsam mit ihren
verbündeten im ukraine konflikt ich
glaube in frankreich ein großes
verständnis für die schwierige situation
in der sich die bundesrepublik befindet
wegen der vergangenheit das ist nicht
irgendwo in der welt wo sich diese
konflikte
sich abzeichnet aber auf der anderen
seite würde man antworten man ist es
gewohnt dass die deutsche außenpolitik
immer ein bisschen
weniger kanten als andere und ich würde
fast sagen ein bestandteil der deutschen
kontinuität ist das ist ein bisschen die
quadratur des kreises man möchte
zugleich multilateral handel aber die
deutschen interessen verteidigen man
möchtest die deutsche schimmelt doch
hören lassen aber zugleich nicht zu sehr
im alleingang auftreten und vor allem
möchte man die menschenrechte
respektieren lassen und irgendwann mal
geraten diese unterschiedlichen ziele in
ja in einen konflikt und
das ist vielleicht auch die schlimmste
periode wo es stattfinden kann ist eine
neue regierung mit einem 3
mit drei mitgliedern mit drei eine
koalition mit drei parteien die sind
nicht so ganz eigentlich alle dass
frankreich ich sehr gut gesehen und man
hat verständnis dass jemand möchte nur
dass die deutschen mit dem franzosen
sagen sind die ukraine dieser konflikt
jetzt auch ziemlich zu uns war ganz am
anfang rv von bredow boris johnson der
marschiert ja mal wieder an der spitze
der bewegung
er will solidarität zeigen mit kiew
russland die grenzen aufzeigen will das
auch den deutschen zeiten oder spielt da
eher innenpolitische gründe im
vereinigten königreich auch eine rolle
im moment spielen da hauptsächlich
innenpolitische gründe eine rolle wie
sie das sicherlich verfolgt haben hat
boris johnson ist im moment in der
schwersten
regierungskrise seit seinem amtsantritt
also es geht um party geht es geht um
unerlaubte partys während des lockt er
uns intern downing street im sitz des
premierministers und er muss wirklich er
muss der letzte woche wirklich um seinen
job fürchten und da kommt es ihm gerade
eigentlich ganz zugegen dass er eben
erfährt ja nach kiew heute er wollte
eigentlich mit der außenministerin des
kras zusammenfahren hat sich da einfach
eigentlich an ihrer reise drangehängt
jetzt ist lässt roche hat positive
corona getestet und muss in london
bleiben er fährt aber alleine und das
lenkt ab von der bredouille in der zu
hause ist also diese ganze dieses diese
keine politik die er im moment verfolgt
ist hauptsächlich von innenpolitischen
erwägungen gelenkt was die fed also
seine außenministerin in kiew heute herr
brunner viele jahre hat die spd die
kanzlerschaft herbeigesehnt und jetzt
das klare signale werden da verlangt in
der sicherheitspolitik ist droht
möglicherweise eine militärische
eskalation
ist es dazu wenig nur auf die
diplomatische karte zu setzen
keineswegs ist es gerade wichtig auch
die diplomatische karte zu setzen
denn auch wenn die sozialdemokratie nun
mehrere jahre darauf warten durfte oder
musste vom wählerinnen von den
wählerinnen und wählern wieder das amt
des kanzlers in die hände gegeben zu
bekommen ist es notwendig dass wir diese
diplomatie in den mittelpunkt stellen
denn schwierige zeiten verlangen
schwierige lösungen schwierige lösungen
haben sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten in der regel immer nach
langen diskussionen ein bekommen und sie
haben es jetzt deshalb bekommen weil sie
der auffassung sind und da bin ich auch
zutiefst überzeugt dass es richtig ist
dass wir diese lösungen gemeinsam mit
den menschen gemeinsam mit den
wählerinnen und wählern gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen partnerinnen und
partnern gemeinsam auf diesem kontinent
wissen müssen und das können wir nicht
militärisch sondern es können wir nur
mit gesprächen einer unserer
sozialdemokratischen vordenker gott hab
ihn selig er durch mit sagt sie immer
lieber 100 mal sprechen als nur ein
einziges mal schießen gut wir werden
noch sehen ob wir es damit einer
sondersituation zu tun haben mit der
ukraine frau henke deutschland wird ja
von allen seiten gedrängt endlich mal
klare kante zu zeigen sowohl gegenüber
der ukraine aber natürlich auch
gegenüber russland um zu zeigen dass man
sich da nicht alles gefallen lässt
spricht eigentlich etwas für die
aktuelle deutsche haltung das einzige
hotel man das so nennen darf ist dass
deutschland gezwungen ist grundsätzliche
fragen strategische fragen zu
beantworten
deutschland muss sich fragen wer ist
unser freund wer ist unser feind in was
für einer welt wollen wir leben und wie
sieht die sicherheitspolitische zukunft
von deutschland aus schöne vorlage zur
nächsten frage die ich dazu stellen
wollte
vom jade lacroix egal wo ein solcher
konflikt auftritt in europa oder bzw
einer der europa betrifft immer wieder
gerät deutschland da auch in die kritik
hat deutschland jetzt was sie was frau
henke da gerade gesagt hatte man muss
definieren welche rolle man spielen will
hat das deutschland versäumt in den
letzten 30 jahren nach 1990 diese rolle
zu suchen zu gestalten und auch zu
definieren und auch zu leben die
deutsche außenpolitik sei der
wiedervereinigung hat auch weiterhin die
kontinuität mit der
bundesrepublikanischen
außenpolitik schon vor der wende und vor
der wiedervereinigung hat der helmut
kohl schon angefangen sehe eindeutig
deutsche interessen vor allem
wirtschaftsinteressen insbesondere in
asien zu vertreten und zu sagen wir
müssen es verbinden irgendwie
menschenrechte achtung der unsere
prinzipien aber auch vertretung der
interessen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass man
das in den deutschen übelnimmt dass die
eigenen interessen vertreten werden die
amtsträger sind auch dazu da sie sind
dafür gewählt dass sie die interessen
ihres landes und auch ihre eigene
wirtschaft vertreten das problem ist in
deutschland im deutschen falle ist dass
diese tradition der politik der
zurückhaltung
insbesondere mit dem mit dem rücken auf
die
betonung der menschenrechte ab und zu
mal deutschland geräten geraten lässt in
eine gewisse scheinheiligkeit das heißt
man verkauft sich als friedlich und
möchte nur liebe und menschenrechte
haben aber wenn es um deutsche
interessen geht dann verteidiger aber
aus französischer sicht auch daran dass
die französische außenpolitik die ja
auch eine außenwirtschaftspolitik ist da
etwas weniger empfindsam ist die
franzosen kein problem rüstungsgüter
nach saudi arabien zu liefern die
wahrscheinlich alle im jemen eingesetzt
werden also da wird ja gar sie was denn
was friedliche entwicklung angeht
kerosin ins feuer gegossen ja aber wenn
so viel ich weiß verkauft bundesrepublik
auch ziemlich viele waffen und das war
ein teil dieses heute ja zumindest in
unserer wahrnehmung wird das kritischer
gesehen als in frankreich oder stimmt
das nicht deshalb kritischer gesehen
aber das war trotzdem gemacht das wird
gemeinsam gemacht mit denen nachbarn
insbesondere in deutschland zwischen
zusammenarbeit aber es war auch
gemeinsam gemacht nach prinzipien die
man versucht zu respektieren
verständlich nicht in krisengebieten die
in konfliktgebieten
aber man es gibt ab und zu mal auch
ausnahmen das heißt man kann so abwägen
politisch wann ist eine rolle spielt
beispielsweise wurden deutsche waffen
geliefert an die kurden gegen den es da
geht es obwohl es in konflikt also
insofern das ist glaube ich der punkt wo
tatsächlich die bundespolitik klare
sprache sprechen soll ist nicht
prinzipien zu haben aber den eindruck zu
erwecken ja wenn es uns besser passt
dann machen wir es trotzdem ich glaube
das ist er das passt nicht zu einer groß
machte inzwischen die waffen im irak
glaube ich auch unter dem eindruck oder
war das unter dem eindruck des
völkermords an den sieben gewesen aber
gut
frau von bredow wir haben jetzt
gesprochen über die deutsche politik die
sich seit 30 jahren das schwer tut eine
neue rolle zu finden für sich in der
weltpolitik dort wo auch deutschland
dringend gefordert ist welche rolle
spielt denn die deutsche gesellschaft
dabei die ist davon ist die politik ja
abhängig sind möchten ja bei der
nächsten wahl wieder gewählt werden ist
die zu pazifistisch diese gesellschaft
zu harmoniesüchtig oder ist sie vor
allen dingen wirtschaftlichen vorteil
interessiert
zu pazifistisch weiß ich nicht aber sie
ist sicher sehr pazifistisch also wenn
man sich die umfragen anschaut ist die
mehrheit der bevölkerung ja nun auch
wirklich gegen waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine und es macht für mich sehr viel
sinn dass deutschland auf jeden fall
vorsichtig ist mit waffenlieferung also
dass da handelt die bundesregierung
sicher im interesse der bevölkerung dass
die ihn ist wenn sie da sehr vorsichtig
ist ich glaube das problem ist
hauptsächlich die kommunikation der
bundesregierung die kamen wirklich jetzt
in letzten wochen als chaotisch war der
eindruck eine chaotische kommunikation
und deutschland haben das war so ein
schlingerkurs und das war und kam
wirklich man hatte den eindruck eines
unsicheren kantonisten und das ist eben
glaube ich wirklich gift für gute
beziehungen mit den verbündeten von
deutschland wenn die den eindruck hat
nervt kann man sich nicht wirklich
verlassen sie sind sich sowieso selbst
in der koalition ohne einig da wissen
wir überhaupt nicht was da aus berlin
kommt das ist glaube ich das viel
größere problem als diese zögerlichkeit
deutschlands waffen zu liefern ich
glaube mit der deutschen geschichte das
verstehen die alliierten die verbündeten
viel besser von deutschland als dieses
ständige solide und hier und man weiß
eigentlich genau wo die deutsche
regierung steht wunder sehen sie das
auch als ein problem an dass dieses
ampel orchester das seit der letzten
bundestagswahl
die töne anschlagen will dass da jeder
nach eigenen noten spielt und dass diese
dissonanzen die dann nach außen dringen
möglicherweise auch eine große hypothek
der deutschen außenpolitik sind
das ist sicherlich eine hypothek unserer
außenpolitik aber das liegt auch ein
bisschen an unserem system wir sind nun
mal keine präsidiale demokratie die mit
mehrheitsverhältnissen arbeitet wie das
mehrheitswahlrecht in frankreich oder
großbritannien dies zur folge gehabt
sondern wir sind im parlamentarischen
demokratie mit einem parlamentarisch
gewählten bundeskanzler und einer
parlamentarischen rat parlament und dem
parlamentarischen kabinett in dem wir
zweifelsohne längere abstimmungsprozesse
benötigen als dies in einem
mehrheitswahlsystem und ein
präsidialsystem der fall ist aber ich
glaube auch dass es eine chance ist eine
chance ist entscheidungen zu finden
entscheidungen bei denen man die
bevölkerung mitnehmen kann und gestatten
sie mir zu den vertreterinnen ob zu
sagen man spricht immer gerne davon
welche rolle deutschland einzunehmen hat
ich sage es ganz offen ja wir müssen
diese frage entscheiden welche rolle
deutschland
sicherheitspolitisch weil die geburten
in deutschland wirtschaftspolitische
welche rolle deutschland in der
europäischen union zu setzen hat aber
die entscheidungen sind wir in
deutschland treffen die müssen wir nicht
übernehmen von irgend jemand der sagt
ihr habt die oder jene rolle zu spielen
sondern wir müssen diese rolle finden
ist nicht einfach das ist ein gleich und
das ist schon gar nicht leicht unter
unserer geschichte und sind wissen dass
wir wie sie sagten ein ausgesprochen
pazifistisches volksstamm ausgesprochen
pazifistischen land sind das
rüstungsexporte waffenexporte als
solches aus dem innersten überzeugungen
schon ablehnt und deshalb ist es
notwendig diese diskussion zu führen
diese debatte zu führen und diese
debatte die wir führen vielleicht und da
gibst du etwas transparenz nach außen zu
bringen als dies tatsächlich der fall
ist möglicherweise muss ich da aber dann
doch einiges ändern in nächster zeit das
werden wir werden wir sehen die
deutschen unter deutschland ist ja nicht
so dass deutschland überhaupt nichts in
die ukraine liefert wie uns in der
vergangenen woche die
bundesverteidigungsministerium in einer
kurzen sitzungspause des
verteidigungsausschusses mitgeteilt
christine lambrecht
wir haben das sofort geprüft und wir
werden 5000 helme an die ukraine liefern
auch als ganz deutliches signal wir
stehen an eurer seite
christine lambrecht das ist jetzt
eigentlich im prinzip nur der aufhänger
zu meiner frage zu sagen muss
deutschland da nicht auch militärisch
robuster werden
auch sich anders ausstatten es gibt ja
schon riesen diskussion auch in der
ampelkoalition wegen des sogenannten 2
prozent ziels der nato also zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsproduktes sollten in
die verteidigungsausgaben gehen wir sind
bei 1,3 oder 1,4 prozent muss ich da
nicht in deutschland auch etwas ändern
weil die internationalen krisen dann
müssen wir nicht nur auf russland
schauen können in zukunft auch noch
massiv zunehmen ganz genau sie nennen
das pazifistisch ich würde sagen die
deutsche bevölkerung hat einen
unglaublichen wunsch neutral zu sein so
praktisch wie die schweiz aber das ist
ein luxus den kann sich deutschland als
das bevölkerungsstärkste land der
europäischen union nicht leisten und es
muss einfach position beziehen und wie
sie selbst schon gerade gesagt haben die
sprache der gewalt die sprache des
krieges die sprache der waffen ist eine
sprache die wird gesprochen die
deutschen haben es verlernen wollen aber
es ist eine sprache die existiert und
die wird jetzt eben gerade auch wieder
und in der ukraine und von russland
angesprochen und deutschland muss wieder
erlernen dort eine rolle
einfach anzunehmen das halte ich für
unglaublich wichtig das heißt also in
der tat jetzt ist dieser konflikt mit
der ukraine mit russland wegen der
ukraine auch wieder eine gelegenheit
sich über diese rolle noch mal klar zu
werden dass wir sozusagen jetzt keine
sonderrolle das ist ja immer der vorwurf
vieler europäischer bündnispartner keine
sonderrolle spielen können ukraine ist
ja nicht so die ukraine ja es ist ja
wirklich ein konflikt der eine
demokratie und gegen eine diktatur er
aufstellt und deutschland muss ich da
ganz klar positionieren und sagen mit
wem bin ich und ich denke deutschland
schuldete er seiner eigenen
vergangenheit schulden der europäischen
idee der europäischen union der
europäischen werten gesellschaft dass
wir uns hier für eine demokratie
einsetzen und ganz klar position
einnehmen auch gegenüber der
menschenrechtsverletzungen die
tagtägliche in russland zum beispiel
vonstatten gehen jetzt haben wir ja der
deutschland ja nicht nur ein problem mit
aufrüstung mit
waffenlieferungen das hat ja die spd
gestern auf ihrer sitzung noch mal klar
abgelehnt so genannte legale waffen also
eine todbringende waffen werden nicht
exportiert was immer die ukraine will
auch nicht diese neuen berüchtigten
panzerhaubitzen aus nva beständen die
gerade in estland sind die aber nur mit
zustimmung des nachfolge regimes der
nachfolge armee nämlich der bundeswehr
weiter exportiert werden dürfen in die
ukraine selbst bei wirtschaftssanktionen
tut man sich momentan schwer selbst gibt
es ja diskussionen der spd ist man ja
nicht bereit ganz klar zu sagen außerdem
zwei liegt auf dem tisch im schnitt ist
alles auf den tisch aber auf nachfrage
liegt trotzdem zwei auch auf dem tisch
wird immer gesagt der soll liegt alles
auf den tisch könnte man meinen es ist
nicht schlimm zwei auch aus dem tisch
diese wirtschaft dieser wirtschaftliche
aspekt ist der auch für frankreich wird
er zu sehr betonen dieser diskussion
wird betonen in dem man betrachtet wie
deutschland sich vom sich positioniert
ich glaube das wäre auch ein bisschen
ungerechte in europäischen verbündeten
gegenüber zu sagen deutschland hat eine
pazifistische bevölkerung also eine
friedfertige bevölkerung als wären die
nachbarn nicht so friedfertig ich glaube
die bevölkerung ist in england in
dänemark in frankreich wie in portugal
wie in allen ländern gehen also genauso
so für den frieden und niemand möchte
den krieg also und das andere ist zu
sagen ja wir lieben so sehr den krieg
dass wir nur helme liefern könne es tut
mir leid aber das ist im ausland wurde
ist ein bisschen ausgelacht ein
französischer korrespondent hat sogar
gesagt wo ist die lieferung von bildungs
stock zu
lieber nichts liefern als händels wirkt
alles noch ein kissen von euch das war
dann der wurde der sport weiter geführt
dass wir in deutschland auch durchaus
nicht so besonders gut aufgenommen
worden war ja auch wie eine fast wie
eine verzweiflungstat oder ja also ich
glaube dass es wäre besser statt nach
einer eigenen alleinigen rolle zu suchen
systematisch im 2 gang zu gehen mit
großbritannien meinetwegen mit
frankreich auf jeden fall denn es ist es
liegt auf der hand dass auch in diesem
normandie format deutschland und
frankreich sehr sehr gut ergänzen
deutschland hat auch mit frau merkel
einen direkten draht auch zu helmut ihn
gehabt und wirkte als
brückenschläge brücken schlagen und so
weiter
präsent makro versucht das sind die
direkt telefoniert mit mit putin ob er
das so allein kann geht es nicht man
kann nicht den franzosen auch vorwerfen
sie machen wollen alles allein in europa
machen und nicht sogleich beistand
leisten ich glaube auch sehr aus paris
ist bob keine enttäuschung sondern eine
bitte um ein zusammengehen und dass man
sagt wir sprechen auch im namen aller
europäer weil wir uns eigentlich sind
auch in wenn es innerhalb der union
einige mitglieder gibt nicht so ganz auf
derselben linie sind die mehrheit
derjenigen die unsere werte verteidigen
sind auf dieser linie und da kann sich
deutschland trauern nicht im alleingang
sondern im zweiten mindestens mit den
anderen zu stimmt ja auch eine
multilaterale organisation wo das
möglich ist im namen der europäer
sprechen herr brunner sie haben ja die
möglichkeit und erleben die auch mit ich
habe gesagt sie sind noch mitglied in
der parlamentarischen versammlung der
nato als ehemaliger
bundestagsabgeordneter erleben sie dass
da auch dass die kritik an der deutschen
position kommt man ist ja in diesen
militärbündnis zusammen ein
verteidigungsbündnis um im falle
militärischer konflikte an einem strang
zu ziehen welche erfahrungen machen sie
da als deutscher vertreter in dieser
parlamentarischen versammlung
also meine erfahrung ist dass die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den vertretern
der nato der europäischen union also
unseren europäischen freunden und der
deutsche eine erfragen ist in der zum
einerseits das verständnis vorhanden ist
gegenseitiges verständnis aber auch das
ringen darüber gemeinsame klare
ergebnisse zu erzielen es gibt aber
ziels die unserem europäischen interesse
sind wir haben immer als deutscher aber
jetzt auch unsere französischen freunde
darauf gedrängt dass die
deutsch-französische zusammenarbeit auch
hier im mittelpunkt steht ich mache aber
keinen hehl daraus dass assoziierte
mitglieder der nato und auch die
vereinigten staaten ganz andere
vorstellungen zum teil haben und ganz
anders argumentieren und vorstellungen
haben so dass deutschland sich jetzt auf
die schnelle und sofort zur partei
erklären soll ich sage ganz bewusst
partei erklären weil unsere rolle die
wir als europäerin oder ob er spielen
können und die will ich dem normandie
format versuchen auf den weg zu bringen
ist sie ungeniert zu sein um frieden in
europa zu erhalten diesen frieden zu
erhalten und gegebenenfalls diesen
frieden auszubauen immer schwierig wenn
man sich als partei bezeichnet oder als
partei versteht und damit diese
scharnierfunktion nicht mehr übernehmen
kann er plädiere ich ganz ausdrücklich
darauf innerhalb der parlamentarischen
versammlung der nato dies aber gemeinsam
mit unseren freunden aus frankreich aus
den benelux-ländern aus italien aus
albanien um nur einige zu nennen dafür
diese scharnierfunktion ich aufzugeben
denn unser ziel muss sein den frieden in
europa zu erhalten und nicht neue gräben
aufzuwerfen die nicht notwendig sind
aufzuwerfen um sicherheit zu
gewährleisten und die stadt in sieben
jahren der stände noch etwas zu sagen
ich halte bei der frage von
menschenrechten als jemand der acht
jahre im deutschen bundestag zur
abrüstung rüstungskontrolle und
nichtverbreitung eingesetzt ich halte
für menschenrechte und die einhaltung
von menschenrechten für sehr wichtig
persönlich finde das schade dass wir in
einer diskussion über menschenrechte
augenblicklich nicht mehr menschen
tracks diskussionen sondern alte kalte
kriegs diskussion entführen und dabei
die größten menschenrechtsverletzungen
dieser zeit passieren nämlich die in
jena aus dem auge verlieren und zu tun
als ob dies nicht da wird und im unter
und lud lustig zu den olympischen
spielen 30 wenn jetzt so gerne wenn
vielleicht diskussionen führen wenn ihre
partei könnte den ein oder anderen oder
die andere geben die zum beispiel
menschenrechts diskussion über russland
und die menschenrechtsverletzungen in
russland nicht so gerne diskutieren sie
haben in china als immer in einer
pluralistischen gesellschaft und in der
politischen partei wird es gebe aber wir
müssen die menschenrechtsverletzungen in
russland die menschenrechtsverletzungen
in china menschenrechtsverletzungen buse
auch immer sinn anprangern und müssen
diese auch so nennen das hat die
vorgänger kanzlerin angela merkel getan
das wird auch olaf scholz zu tun und
eine menschenrechts geleitete politik
ist notwendig aber diese menschen rechts
geleitet die politik muss nicht
zwangsläufig dazu führen partei zu
werden aufzurüsten und versuchen die
lösung militärisch zu erreichen frau von
brad und jetzt gibt es ja eine umfrage
in deutschland ich glaube sogar mehreren
umfragen dass ja die bevölkerung in
deutschland zwar die gefahr eines
konfliktes mit russland sieht wegen der
ukraine oder wegen osteuropa
aber die mehrheit eigentlich dafür ist
weder wirtschaftssanktionen zu erlassen
und schon gar keine waffen zu liefern
das wird ja dann immer als
beschwichtigung gegenüber russland
bezeichnet jetzt ist es ja so vielleicht
kommen diese beschwichtigungen gegenüber
russland ja auch daher dass man im
winter ungarn auf dem im kalten sitzt
ist das auch ein das ist ja auch ein
wesentlicher antrieb da ist ja
deutschland auch besonders abhängig von
russland
da ist deutschland besonders abhängig
von russland nicht nur deutschland ich
mein österreich und andere länder auch
aber deutschland ist halt größer als die
anderen die so abhängig sind von dem
russischen erdgas und da hat sich
deutschland natürlich auch sehr
verletzbar gemacht indem also unter frau
merkel entschieden wurde gleichzeitig
aus der nuklearenergie und kohle
auszusteigen und dadurch wurden diese
russischen erdgaslieferungen eben noch
wichtiger und es gibt nicht wirklich an
der alternative deutschland braucht das
russische gas nicht um nicht zu frieren
und anders als braucht russland
natürlich auch das einkommen wir
brauchen auch was was die deutschen
ihnen zahlen aber im moment sitzt die
russische zentralbank auf ich glaube 600
milliarden dollar reserven dh sie können
sich auch leisten das irgendwie
eskalieren zu lassen was ich eigentlich
glaube dass sie wollen aber dass das
wäre möglich also sie haben dieses
dieses kissen aber das sagen wir und
deshalb haben ja auch die verbündeten
deutschlands gewisses verständnis für
die deutsche position erklären weil
natürlich frankreich hat diese
verletzbarkeit nicht frankreich ist
nicht vom russischen gas so abhängig
also das spielt eine große rolle und das
spielt natürlich auch eine große rolle
mit not seem to darüber haben wir jetzt
noch nicht so viel geredet aber immerhin
hat der bundeskanzler ja da schon
positionen gesagt also gesagt wenn es
also wirklich zum konflikt kommt dann
wird dann dann ist auch not seem to wird
nicht
da wird kein gas durch nutzen zu gepumpt
werden nur zum 2 also da das hat er zwar
lange damit gewartet aber das wurde
immerhin schon gesagt aber nur um kurz
zu sagen die hat deutschland hat diese
dieser schwachstelle diese große
schwachstelle sind das energie- und die
energiepartnerschaft mit russland
gescheitert angesichts dieser tatsachen
dass wir jetzt nicht nur abhängig sind
dass die energiepreise durch die decke
gehen dass wir nicht wissen wie sich das
weiter entwickelt ob das gas doch noch
als waffe benutzt wird wir aber glaube
ich 55 prozent des erdgases und 40
prozent des erdöls aus russland beziehen
war das eine leichtsinnige strategie und
ist diese partnerschaft mit russland
gescheitert
unser kollege von der spd wandel durch
handel die ostpolitik das ist natürlich
die seine expertise aber die idee glaube
ich würde ich ein bisschen
missverstanden ja man habe immer gedacht
in den 90er jahren den 2000er jahren bis
vor kurzem diesem wandel durch handel
philosophie könnte mit russland immer
noch weiter von staatlichen weil sie hat
ja auch eine gewisse weise während des
kalten krieges funktioniert wenn man das
rum groben sagen darf zumindest in den
letzten zehn jahren den 80er jahren aber
ich sehe einen fundamentalen unterschied
zwischen den 80er jahren und heute vor
allem gorbatschow wollte wirklich wandel
er hat sich dafür interessiert er wusste
dass in der sowjetunion fehler gemacht
worden sind er wollte das das
empire und erregend er wollte es
reformieren wenn ich mir jetzt gerade
dass putin regime anschaue sehe ich
diesen willen nicht und das ist auch die
große frage die ich eben habe man kann
nur diesen wandel einführen wenn man
weiß wo da ist auch eine bereitschaft
von der anderen seite für diesen sind
wir vielleicht im westen nicht auch
schuld an dieser situation hätten wir
nach 1990 nicht sehr viel mehr auf die
bedürfnisse der sowjetunion eingehen
müssen haben wir die irgendwie auch
sicherheitspolitisch am langen arm
verhungern lassen sie sagen ja am
schluss so aus wie als seien wir
gönnerhaft würden wir jetzt russland
irgendwie noch mit einbeziehen aber
wirklich ernst genommen wirklich als
gleichberechtigten partner da hatte man
nicht das gefühl in den 1990 er jahren
dass das so ist
wissen sie die sowjetunion hat den
kalten krieg verloren das muss man auch
mal ganz klar sagen das hat er so weder
nun auch ganz klar gesagt das hat glaube
ich helmut kohl gesagt vor allem aber
der damalige us präsident george bush
senior
ich mag nicht verlieren sie mögen
wahrscheinlich auch nicht verlieren aber
wenn man verliert dann kann man einfach
nicht mehr die neuen spielregeln setzen
das ist einfach so und das musste auch
die sowjetunion akzeptieren bzw hat
natürlich in diesem moment die usa oder
am besten auch das gespielt was ist
spielen konnte als de facto gewinner des
kalten krieges natürlich hätte man da
vielleicht großzügiger sein können aber
so ist eben die welt im internet war der
westen zu überheblich gewesen in dieser
frage 1990 folgende jahre dass man eben
die russen also die damals noch die
sowjetunion später russland hat spüren
lassen ihr habt den kalten krieg
verloren ich glaube die europäer
vielleicht weniger als die amerikaner
und man es hat auch mehrere in europa
gegeben die gesagt haben vorsicht
georgien erweiterung der nato auf
georgen oder so weiter das wäre zuviel
als das heißt man muss sich auch an die
stelle des anderen stellen aber die art
und weise wie russland heute
argumentiert und regelrecht lügt
entschuldigung wie die behauptung es
hätte versprechen gegeben keine nato
osterweiterung
jetzt in der letzten zeit hat heute
glaube ich sogar offenen brief geschickt
an die andere seite darunter der wir
sind in dem er sagt ja sind versprechen
und verträge verletzt worden wenn man
sich darauf bezieht zu sagen man hätte
1990 versprochen die nato nicht nach
osten als zu erweitern das möchte man
aber gerne sehen in den akten finden sie
nichts dergleichen oder auch wenn es
mündlich gesagt worden ist wenn man die
anders machen sollen ja aber wenn man
die akten kennt weiß man das immer
gesprächsprotokolle geführt sie hätten
damit zu fuß oder immer wieder auf
spieler oder deutschen zone rolle es war
ja so also eine es gab keine zusage
danach über das glaub ich gar nicht
gesprochen worden dass sich die nadel
nicht nach osten erweitert es wurde nur
versprochen dass man dauerhaft in den
osteuropäischen staaten keine
nato-truppen
entschuldigung ist so ist es nicht ist
es in dem in dem so genannten
zwei-plus-vier-vertrag also vertrag zu
acht ließen den regelungen der deutschen
frage von september 90 wurde verhandelt
und wurde im artikel 5 absatz 3 gesagt
dass auf dem gebiet der ehemaligen ddr
also den künftigen neuen bundesländer
keine auswärtigen truppen stationiert
weder verlegt werden aber damals war gar
nicht die rede von ost erweiterung der
nato die damals standen aber damals
bestand der warschauer pakt und man
konnte sich nicht vorstellen dass der
warschauer pakt nicht existiert dass die
sowjetunion existiert und dass die nato
sich aus nach osten erweitert insofern
ist es eine ex post konstruktion die man
sehr wohl verstehen kann man kann das
nachvollziehen dass die russen gesagt an
hoppla da ist etwas passiert wo wir die
kontrolle verloren haben und wo die
mitteleuropäischen staaten die das
bedürfnis hatten ihre ihr bündnis zu
wählen aber das ist da können sie mich
korrigieren glaube ich 1999 wieder
festgelegt worden die bündnis wahl ist
ein prinzip aber jetzt diskutieren die
russen und sagen ja aber die bündnis
wahl darf die nachbarn nicht
für die nachbarn keine gefahr sein wieso
soll ist eine gefahr für russland sein
wenn die nachbarn nato zugehörig sein
das ist eine konstruktion um sich zu
amüsieren
darf ich kurz ganz gut sagen ich finde
die zeit punkte die sie erwähnt haben
ganz wichtig ja weil nämlich als die
ersten deklaration gemacht wurden das
eben nato osterweiterung stattfindet hat
damals die russische regierung gar
nichts gesagt dass das große die große
aufruhr kamen dann bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz in 2008 und da muss
man auch so ein bisschen verstehen was
ist im innenpolitisch vonstatten
gegangen und hier nur ganz kurz heute
hat putin ein unglaublich in politisches
system er hat keine legitimität durch
wahlen er hat keine legitimität durch
wirtschaftswachstum die einzigste
legitimität die er noch hat ist eben die
bedrohung von dem westen die bedrohung
von nato putin braucht einen feind und
deshalb ist diese ganze debatte ost
erweiterung hin oder her wie legitim wie
kritisch wie gefährlich ein konstrukt
das
innenpolitisch von absoluten von unten
und notwendigkeit ist aber ob das
wirklich so real eine bedrohung ist
weiblich
herr brunner wenn wir jetzt sehen dass
russland sich vielleicht ungerecht
behandelt gefühlt hat wenn es
zurückkehren will jetzt auf augenhöhe
mit anderen großmächten wie china oder
den usa ist auch unter diesem aspekt
nicht die haltung der spd gegenüber
russland doch zu unkritisch mit
sicherheit ist die haltung der spd nicht
unkritisch auf jeden fall nicht
unkritisch als die von frau henke ich
war versucht zu sagen in welcher
realität gelieben sie wenn ich heute in
die russische föderation sehe und ich
sage an dieser stelle ganz klar dass ich
das system putin die dortige autokratie
als solches aus tiefster überzeugung
demokrat ablehne aber ich muss auch zur
kenntnis nehmen dass das größte land der
erde sollte es morgen demokratische
wahlen nach unserem standard geben
wieder werde ich mich vor den wellen
würde weil er eine hohe zustimmung in
seinem land hat und mit dieser realität
müssen auch nie erleben können drittens
auf boden europas und auf den boden oder
rasieren mehr eine auseinandersetzung
haben
denen die menschen die zeche zu bezahlen
haben weil ideologien im mittelpunkt
sich die ideologie darf nicht im
mittelpunkt sein und genau das ist es
was die sozialdemokratie in meinen augen
derzeit in der diskussion auszeichnet
wir wollen keine ideologische
auseinandersetzung sondern als in der
auseinandersetzung um den frieden in
europa darf ich kurz darüber wickelten
ja ich denke wenn man sich so sicher ist
in seiner politischen position dann muss
man so leute wie alexei navalny
opposition nicht vergiften nicht
umbringen dann muss man nicht so einen
repressiven staat führen wie putin das
führt also wenn sie sagen putin hat so
dass eine demokratische legitimität dann
frage ich mich warum dann diese massive
repression der oppositionellen in
russland
ich sag nur einmal ganz klar er will
putin hat derzeit keine demokratische
legitimität wäre aber eine demokratische
wahl in russland der fall würde er sie
als solches erhalten man muss nur in
russland die ohren offen halten mit den
menschen sprechen mit den akteuren
sprechen die es so was gibt und zwar
nicht mit denen die in den eliten es
sich denken mit europa sprechen zu
müssen und mit den vereinigten staaten
sondern die ganz einfachen leuten ich
sagen ein beispiel ich war jetzt letzte
woche mit der parlamentarischen
versammlung der nato in brüssel sei es
mitunter hinein am tisch die bleibe ein
anderes verständnis zur russischen
föderation haben als wir in der
europäischen union ist haben aber alle
haben mir das gleiche signalisiert das
bedauerliche ist wenn es in russland
demokratische wahlen gäbe dann wäre
putin wieder mehrheitlich mit der
gleichen mehrheit wie er sich das
vorstellt aber mit einer demokratischen
mehrheit immer wieder lücken vertreten
und das ist eine realität mit ihrer
leben ist und da müssen wir ansetzen
welche angebote können wir der
russischen föderation geben dass sie
wieder zurück in diese demokratische
familie in diese familie europas kommt
nicht möchte russland weiter aus europa
heraus bringen sondern in menschen aus
russland und deren wirtschaft wieder in
die europäische union und nach europa
parlament
putin sich so sicher sein kann dass er
die wahlen gewinnt könnte ja auch freie
wahlen abhalten lassen ich habe noch
eine frage an sich als spd-mitglied über
gerhard schröder gibt es aus ihrer sicht
für einen ehemaligen also ein
bundeskanzler der nicht mehr im amt ist
trotzdem die verpflichtung den
interessen seines landes weiterhin zu
dienen er wird von einem mann bezahlt
der im dringenden verdacht steht die
demokratie und den rechtsstaat in
deutschland die stabilisieren zu wollen
ist das etwas was mit dem
amtsverständnis auch eines ehemaligen
bundeskanzlers vereinbar ist
das muss jeder mit sich selbst ausmachen
das amtsverständnis also jetzt fast oder
nicht ich darf auf jeden fall
feststellen dass das was in den letzten
tagen gerd schröder
über alle podcast gesagt hat ist nicht
unbedingt meine volle zustimmung hat
aber auch in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung und den medialen wiedergabe
ist nicht ganz dem wortlaut entsprochen
hat und deshalb glaube ich immer genau
darauf schauen genau sehen was man zu
tun hat und wenn man in deutschland
regelungen treffen will dass
bundeskanzler künftig keine
privatwirtschaftliche tätigkeit mehr
ausüben dürfen dann muss man das ganz
deutlich sagen das muss dann für alle
aber ein schöner dass sie jetzt sagen
ist mir eigentlich gerhard schröder
faktisch in schutz mit dieser äußerung
es fällt ja auch dass die spd sich von
ihm nicht distanziert dass ihm geradezu
in der russland frage mit
glacéhandschuhen anfasst in diesen
handschuhen stecken die gleichen
sozialdemokratischen hände die in einer
anderen frage aber gerhard schröder am
liebsten an die gurgel gehen wird
nämlich war agenda 2010 und hartz 4
warum diese unterschiedliche umgehens
weise mit dem ehemaligen bundeskanzler
ich habe da keine unterschiedliche
vorgehensweise ich habe im übrigen die
agenda 2010 für richtige also für heute
noch für richtig und deshalb glaube ich
nicht dass sie mir anschaute sie haben
gerade die ode an schuhe anhat ich hatte
nie wird sie auch nicht auf frau von
plate auch wenn wir jetzt aber haben sie
die jetzige situation es wird noch
diskutiert ist kritik an deutschland
franzosen amerikaner briten preschen vor
wollen auch waffenlieferungen
seismischen begonnen waffen zu die dann
wird aus ihrer sicht deutschland wenn
die situation weiter eskaliert wenn
diplomatie eben sich nicht durchsetzt um
waffenlieferungen herum kommen also
dieses klaren nein der spd dass das
nochmal aufgeweicht wird auch innerhalb
der spd
also wenn sozusagen was gott verhüten
ist wirklich eskaliert der konflikt
eskaliert dann wird sich deutschland
meiner ansicht nach und das hoffe ich
natürlich auch ganz klar auf die seite
von den
amerikanern und den westlichen
verbündeten stellen das hat der
bundeskanzler ja auch zwar sehr
vorsichtig aber hat das auch angedeutet
und dann nehme ich auch an dass wenn das
nötig ist und das wird wahrscheinlich
nötig seien deutschland waffen liefern
wird die hoffnung ist natürlich nach wie
vor das dass es nicht dazu kommt aber
man wird sehen aber ich aber ich bin
noch ziemlich sicher dass deutschland
dann ganz klar position beziehen wird
sie ist es auch so aus dass das
möglicherweise also bei den
wirtschaftssanktionen kann man sich ja
vorstellen dass auch zudem zwei dann
sozusagen über die wupper geht und nicht
mehr realisierbar ist bei einem angriff
auf die ukraine aber bei
waffenlieferungen halten sie das für
möglich ich hatte nicht die deutsche
position dann noch mal ändern ich glaube
vor allem nicht dass das von deutschland
erwartet wird also ich es ist nicht so
sehr das problem das ist auch vorher von
frau von bredow gesagt worden was bei
den nachbarn und bei denen verbündeten
und den freunden ein bisschen störend
ist das ist das nicht klartext
gesprochen wird nicht unbedingt also die
ich muss es wiederholen die franzosen
beispielsweise aber auch die anderen
westlichen nachbarn haben viel
verständnis dafür dass deutschland sich
in einer besonderen situation befindet
dass dieser konflikt nicht sehr weit von
deutschland ist und b weil es diese
geschichte gibt mit den in den dem
hitler-regime also insofern wird nicht
von deutschland erwartet dass waffen
geliefert werden dann lieber sollte man
es alles lassen sogar die helme aber
erwartet wird die klare positionierung
und zusagen menschenrechte das ist keine
ideologie menschenrechte oder wenn das
eine ideologie ist es ist unsere und das
ist das prinzip das sind die prinzipien
auf denen unser unser unserer gestaltung
der welt eine friedfertige gestaltung
der welt kann man gedanken
menschenrechte wieder herstellen ja das
ist ein ständiges problem in der
philosophie ob gewalt anwender ist um
überhaupt frieden wiederherzustellen
bekanntlich hat deutschland auch in den
aktionen der wir der vereinten nation
nach dem deutschland sich lange jahre
zurückgehalten hat nie an wieder ein
friedens wiederherstellende aktion
teilgenommen hat und das kann man
verstehen also ich glaube das wäre es
wäre falsch zu glauben dass die ganze
welt von deutschland erwartet dass
wieder wieder deutschland zu einem
militär aktiven staat wird was aber
erwartet wird ist dass das gewicht
deutschlands das ist nicht nur ein
wirtschaftliches gewicht sondern auch
ein politisches in bevölkerungs mäßiges
gewicht in die balance gesetz wird auf
der richtigen seite multilateral mit den
anderen zusammen aber dass nicht der
eindruck entsteht und am ende gewinnen
die deutschen firmen weil man sich so
engagiert hat damit man deutschland nur
für seine wirtschaftlichen interessen
interessiert dass mit den
waffenlieferungen hat ja möglicherweise
wird auch hier und deswegen nicht
hinkommen oder dazu kommen in
deutschland weil es ja eine ganz große
koalition gibt es nicht und die spd die
gegen waffenlieferungen ist und die
grünen will durch märz hat angst um die
aktienmärkte sollten wir die russen aus
leben in der nationalen zahlungssystems
licht werfen markus söder hat am sonntag
ganz klar gesagt waffen das sieht er
nicht das ist doch eine positionierung
das heißt an daran kommen auch die
verbündeten nicht vorbei
waffenlieferungen jetzt weiß ich ja von
gefragt habt wird es doch zu
waffenlieferungen kommen es muss aber
sagen nein wir das auf keinen fall
wissen sie zu ihrer vorherigen frage
hier in diesem land 1945 wurde
militärisch wieder menschenrechte
eingesetzt ja in diesem land wohl der
völkermord militärisch gestoppt weil sie
gesagt haben kann man militärisch sie
sich für menschenrechte einsetzen kann
man militärisch was gute sozusagen
erreichen dieses landes der beste beweis
dass jahr manchmal ist militärgewalt
eben vonnöten um gewisse ziele zu
erreichen aber ich denke ich
stimme ja meiner vorrednerin verlegte
mit ein es geht hier nicht um
waffenlieferungen
die amerikaner liefern jetzt 60
milliarden dollar waffen zu der ukraine
es geht hier einfach um ein signal von
deutschland zu sagen wir sind mit nato
wir sind mit dem westen und wir können
einfach freund und feind unterscheiden
und dann natürlich geht es dann um die
sanktionspolitik und hier hat glaube ich
auch deutschland so ein bisschen
missverstanden wie überhaupt
abschreckung funktionieren abschreckung
funktioniert wenn man ganz klar sagt
das implementieren wir und übrigens sie
hier finde ich den nato doppelbeschluss
und und die politik von helmut schmidt
unglaublich erfolgreich die einfach
gesagt hat wir stellen die pershing
raketen auf aber gleichzeitig sind wir
auch dazu bereit zu verhandeln und genau
so eine einstellung sollte jetzt auch
ein weder von bredow ich habe am anfang
gesagt dass möglicherweise willy brandt
nicht das richtige historische vorbild
ist ist es denn helmut schmidt was frau
henke gerade gesagt hat
also dieser name soll beschloss diese
flexible antwort
ja also in der jetzigen situation würde
ich auch sagen wir wir bräuchten eher
helmut schmidt oder olaf scholz sollte
sich an
helmut schmidt ein vorbild nehmen und
nicht so sehr bei willy brandt ich meine
man muss auch sagen dass bisher das ist
ja der erste große außenpolitische tests
der neuen regierung und ich glaube wenn
man eine note gibt es ist es
unbefriedigend bisher nicht das ist
einfach die die kommunikation ist zu
unklar und zu zögerlich und ich stimme
ganz meinen zwei vorrednerin zu dass es
dass es eben es geht eben nicht wirklich
um die waffenlieferungen per se sondern
es geht um eine klare position und das
gefühl wir haben da einen ganz
verlässlichen verbündeten und dieses
gefühl ist eben von berlin nicht
vermitteln und nicht genügend und das
ist leider also vielleicht ist es doch
eher ausreichend als befriedigend also
die die note ist nicht sehr gut also das
ist aber noch nicht versetzung gefährdet
herr brunner wir haben noch zehn
sekunden haben oder helmut schmidt für
sie vielleicht doch das bessere
historische beispiel vorbild
helmut schmidt jetzt sicherlich immer
ein gutes beispiel und gutes vorbild
dabei ich willy brandt nicht außer acht
lassen will muss seine politik nie
aufbauen können wenn es nicht die
entspannungs politik willy brandts
gegeben gut dann bedanke ich mich bei
ihnen ich bedanke mich bei allen im jahr
hat den acker bei marina henke bei wenn
die linie von bredow und bei karl heinz
brunner liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde nach neunten zurück zu
welchen kosten im die ice t jetzt folgt
phoenix der tag mit anja chalet das
thema unter anderem darin der mord an
den beiden polizisten der polizistin und
den polizisten im saarland bleiben sie
bei uns
[Musik]